guys, I will quickly break down the trade that was sent out in the discord. So let's go to the weekly
time frame first. And on the weekly, what I saw was that we took out external liquidity here.
And I also saw the internal liquidity down there. Now once price took out the external,
I just dropped down to the four hours timeframe. And from here onwards, what I was looking for,
was a market structure shift. And just around here, we got the shift in the market structure.
Now from here onwards, which you can see is that we had this autoblock here.
Like that price came back into our autoblock. We did get our entry here,
right? But as you can see, we have this consolidation phase here. So we can,
I looked at the market maker model here, and also the internal liquidity, it was still there.
And this was the only PD array that I had in my mind, because this is a clean autoblock. So,
and we also had these equal highs around this level. So this was a very high probability setup.
Now once price came back into our autoblock, I simply dropped down to 15 minutes timeframe.
Now price came into our autoblock. So now I looked at the economic
calendar. And today was the news at 8.30. So I would be taking my trades after 8.30. So
over here, we had a market structure shift, but considering the fact that considering the
Asian session trading strategy, you can see that the Asian high was still there. So this is
basically a liquidity point. So you cannot take a short position because price will take out the high
or low. So what happened price took out the high, then we have the, we had a shift in the market
structure around here, right? And we had this clean autoblock. Now this is when the news even
occurred at 8.30, we took our entry at around 8.45. And boom, look at that. The price just
just went down like that.